[Music]  here's one a whole copy to a book called  distracted while orgasming oh yeah look  at this one right here she's thinking  gas bill five days ago right there left  wet towel out of good floor we've all  been there this have to take Schnauzer  in for its shots  [Applause]  how didn't love that one  no I don't know why  it's just a coffee table book I found  sure I know well I'm a fan of stock  photos and that was those are some great  stock bonus on that you're gonna like  this one  first hold for edit there you go anyway  our next one trust me I know what I'm  doing when you watch the show tonight  folks you're not gonna see that goddamn  door dad they'll be telling their  friends I'm telling you I saw it I went  to the taping wasn't on the show anyway  [Music]  you